en l'espace de quelques heures deux
bombardements ont fait deux morts et
causé des dommages considérables dans la
capitale de l'ukraine les cibles en
immeubles résidentiels in usines
aéronautiques
pour l'occasion le maire de kiev est
venu constater les dégâts l'ancien
champion de boxe créer une
intensification des attaques
la moitié des habitants de kif quitter
la capitale la journaliste et you know
garde cover a quitté la capitale pour
s'installer dans le sud ouest du pays à
400 km de là son mari et son père sont
toujours à kiev pour prêter main forte
les routes sont barrées la circulation
est difficile justement à cause de
checkpoint un partout voilà donc la
ville ce n'est plus la vie normale c'est
le premier but d'avancé c'est un peu
désert pendant tout cas à moitié déserte
les combats se sont poursuivis bien au
delà de la capitale près du centre
historique de kharkiv dans l'est du pays
un immeuble résidentiel a été la cible
des missiles deux personnes y ont perdu
la vie
et à donetsk les forces séparatistes pro
russes ont accusé l'ukraine d'avoir visé
le centre ville et d'avoir institué au
moins 16 personnes l'armée kényane a
fermement rejeté l'accusation
un mario paul des images de drones
captée par une unité de défense
nationale ukrainienne montre l'étendue
des dommages faits à des quartiers
résidentiels des habitants aborde 160
voitures ont pu quitter la ville
assiégée en empruntant un corridor
humanitaire
autre mauvais type qui est d'origine
chevronnés pauvre noté mme hay hassani
biz
procès
par ailleurs les autorités sont revenus
sur le tristement célèbre bombardement
d'un hôpital pédiatrique la semaine
dernière pour confirmer le décès de la
femme qu'on aperçoit ici sur une civière
et celui de son bébé qu'elle portait
malgré la destruction il est mort
certains d'ukrainiens reste optimiste et
choisissent de rester pour eddy comme
ici dans la ville portuaire de dessin
[Musique]
depuis bientôt deux semaines des
résidents se relaie pour remplir des
sacs de sable pour freiner
éventuellement l'arrivée des forces
russes je dirais quand même que la
grande majorité des ukrainiens jusqu'à
90 % croient plus l'écrin sortira
vainqueur de cette guerre puisque
c'était hier à absolument inutile
absolument absurde si la majorité de la
population est au jour en ukraine l'onu
rapporte aujourd'hui que ce sont plus de
2 8 millions de personnes qui ont quitté
le pays depuis le début de la guerre un
flot de réfugiés que l'europe n'avait
pas connue depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale si pascal harrison juliette au
canada montréal